ما ذكرته يعد ضمن اسلحه حرب التطبيقات
الطاحنه بين الصين وامريكا الدولتان
اللتان تسعيان حرفيا للسيطره على العالم
تكنولوجيا كما تعلمون يواجهوا التيك توك
الذي يستخدمه نحو 150 مليون شخص في امريكا
مشروع قانون في الكونجرس لحظره بشكل كامل
في الولايات المتحده بتهمه التجسس لمصلحه
بكين ونشر المحتوى الخطير وهو ما تنفيه
اداره التطبيق المملوك لشركه باي دانس
الصينيه لكن تيك توك المنافس البارز ايضا
لتطبيقات شركه ميتا على صداره السوشيال
ميديا عالميا لم يهدا فبتزامن مع حرب حظري
اعلن مؤخرا عن خطه لاطلاق خدمه
المحتوى الطويل بحيث يمكنهم انتاج مواد
تصل مدتها لعشرين دقيقه وهو
ضربه قويه لمنصه يوتيوب
فصل اخر شهدته هذه الحرب قبل ايام قليله
فقط عندما سجل تطبيق
عدد مرات تحميل عاليه جدا في امريكا فهذا
التطبيق المملوك ايضا اصبح منافسا شرسا
لمنصه انستجرام رغم اطلاقه في عام 2020 ما
احدثه ليمون ايت اعتبره خبراء مناوره ذكيه
من الشركه الصينيه للبقاء في السوق
الامريكي في حاله صدور قرار يحضر تيك توك
بشكل نهائيا اخر فصول الحرب الطاحنه هو
اعلان شركه علي بابا الصينيه اليوم عن
خطتها لاطلاق روبوت دردشه على غرار
الصيني يحمل اسم تمديد شان ون اي الجواب
من الف سؤال وسيؤدي عددا من المهام ابرزها
تحويل المحادثات في الاجتماعات الى
ملاحظات مكتوبه وكتابه رسائل البريد
الالكتروني وغيرها من المهمه المشابهه
لتشات جي بي تي في النهايه يطرح سؤال يشغل
بال الكثيرين من الذي سينتصر واشنطن
امبيكين